Okay, so what do you think?
>> I think the answer would be a and b and any of those four: c, d, e or f.
>> Alright. So let's think about what would happen in that
case. So, if we start off the centers there. The first
step is going to be for every point to join whichever
cluster it's closest to. So, a is just going to be with a.
>> Mm-hm.
>> B is just going to be with b. And then
d is going to slurp up all these other four points.
>> Right.
>> All right.
So now in the next iteration, it's going to recompute the centers. And a
and b aren't going to change. This cluster,
the center's going to change to here. And
now it's never going to make any additional progress. So those are the three
clusters it'll find if it starts off with those kind of bad initial points.
>> So how would we go about avoiding that sort of thing?
>> yes. I was going to ask you exactly that question. So, given
that we're thinking about this as a
hill climbing process, that's a local optimum.
And we had a pretty good way of dealing
with local optima and that was random restarts. That's
one possibility. Another thing that people sometimes do is
they'll do a quick analysis of the space and actually
try to find initial cluster centers that kind of
are spread out. So pick a cluster center and then
pick the next cluster center to be as far
away from all the other cluster centers as you can.
>> So kind of do like the, I don't know, the convex
hole of the space and try to pick points near the corners or
something like that?
>> Yes, yeah, that's right.
>> Hm. So I think you've done another thing too, now
that I say that out loud. Which is, you've been choosing
these random places to start your centers as always being one
of the points. I guess you didn't have to do that.
>> Yes.
>> But it probably helps that you do.
>> It certainly keeps the centers near the points. Another thing you
can do to get things started is just randomly assign everybody the clusters
but that can often have the property that all of
the senders of those clusters end up being kind of really
close to each other. So, by picking points to be
the clusters it does have a tendency to spread things out.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> That's not a proof, though.
>> No, a proof by that makes sense. [LAUGH]